hey everyone it's Mike from workflows
and welcome back to my channel you know
in today's video I'm going to talk about
um in order for a strategy that you know
is one of my favorites and to be honest
it sort of gets lost in all the types of
order flow analysis that we do nowadays
you know based on things like Delta
point of control obviously imbalances
volume Etc and it is the Stacked
imbalances you know stacked behind
imbalances and stacked selling
imbalances so
um let's dive deeper into it because you
know it's sometimes the simple things
are something that you can wrap your
head around a lot easier than some of
the more complex things so what is a
stacked imbalance well first of all
we've got to talk about a stacked
imbalance now this is a you know your
normal basic footprint chart that's
available on most softwares now and you
know when I first started trading with
order flow and you know introduced to it
back in in the late 2000s this is what
chart looked like right it was your
basic footprint with the volume traded
on the bid the volume traded on the
offer you can see where there were
imbalances in the two-way auction you
can see where the point of control was
you can see what the Delta was you know
the volume Etc but that was that was
pretty much it you know now we've got
all sorts of tools for identifying
what's actually taking place in the
order flow right where value is
developing where there's exhaustion
things like that but today I just want
to sort of keep it simple back to the
basics if you will and talk about the
Stacked imbalances so an imbalance
occurs in the two-way auction right
there's always there's a bid and there's
an offer and when you have an imbalance
in that two-way auction depending on
where it comes if it comes in
um if it's an aggressive buying
imbalance you know the volume that
trades in the footprint is going to show
a blue collar because it's aggressive
buying if it is a red color in the
footprint that signifies aggressive
selling right 75 contracts traded on the
bid at 63 and a quarter versus uh 13
that traded at 63 and a half right so
that's a selling a balance now the
numbers that are black in the footprint
is just your normal order flow it
doesn't reach the threshold to be
considered an imbalance because you know
remember an imbalance or that aggressive
trading rather aggressive trading is
what causes the markets to move because
there's a bid there's an offer somebody
doesn't cross that bid offer line the
Market's not going to move it's just
going to stay stagnant okay and when you
have more aggressive trading by a
certain percentage I use four to one
that's sort of the industry standard
where most people start but again that
that's not set in stone you know some
people use three to one three hundred
percent some people use you know 10 to
one obviously the higher number you go
the less imbalances you're going to see
in the market all right so what is a
stacked imbalance well that's an
imbalance where you have
um three or more imbalances decked
neatly on top of each other either
buying imbalances or selling imbalances
right
now
most order flow charts will again
identify the imbalances in there right
but they don't always identify when it's
stacked and people say well do I really
need to see that you know well it just
visually makes it easier for you as a
Trader right you know the we live in
this age of you know Instagram Pinterest
Facebook and uh and God forbid I throw
Tick Tock in there but um you know where
we process you know images much faster
than words or numbers right a footprint
chart is is basically numbers so being
able to identify where you have a
stacked buying and balance or a stacked
selling a balance is going to draw your
attention to hey you know what
something's happening right now in the
market and really when you're watching
order flow analyzing the order flow you
know you want to be alerted when
something is happening in the market you
know as soon as it happens right order
flow is best used when you know you take
advantage of it as it happens so you
know on my order flows Trader we have a
setting in there for stacked imbalances
and there's two ways you can look at
them first one I'll just show you as
fixed and what that is that will just
draw it out it'll highlight the Stacked
imbalance in the bar which is you know
is nice to see right because we you know
we want to be alerted to it we think
that I'll be able to pick that up but
sometimes you know we're in the heat of
trading and maybe sometimes you know we
got something on and you know we just
might Overlook it so you can see here
right the Stack's selling a balance
here's the stack buying and balance
another stacked buying a balance another
stacked buying a balance and that's all
well and good but you know what you've
got to take it a step further because
when you have aggressive overly
aggressive trading you know something
that's causing an imbalance in the
market
um you know you know that there is
something happening in the market right
because why why is there so much
aggressive trading that the market is
out of balance right if it was just
black numbers in the footprint
that would be your normal Market
facilitating trade but now you have it
lopsided so to speak okay and when you
have that happening sometimes that
generates support or resistance levels
right these are Market generated support
or resistance levels now I'm not saying
that these levels are going to hold
forever but when you see this aggressive
trading oftentimes the market is going
to come back to test that level
and what you what you want to see is can
this Market
um bounce off that level or was that
aggressive trading maybe just the result
of a big order going through the market
right and it just had to get through the
market for whatever reason maybe I just
I just get me out of the position I
don't care the price boom you know buys
300 and just sweeps up through the
market sometimes it's a big Trader uh
maybe he knows something right or I'll
say knows something but rather you know
has an inclination of you know something
big is about to happen in the market so
what I like to do right and this is one
of the features of the order of close
Traders draw out a Zone from those
levels okay and it's simple all you got
to do is you find the Stacked and
balance and change it from fixed to
until tested and what that's going to do
is going to draw out kind of this green
zone from where the Stacked imbalance is
or a Red Zone from where the Stacked
cylinder balance is and so now I know on
my chart I don't have to draw lines let
the software do it you know I'm not one
of these people oh I gotta draw a
slanted line here or draw a Zone let the
computer do it for you so here right I
know that I have a stack behind a
bouncer so I know I got aggressive
Traders coming in here I want to see
what happens when the market comes back
to it right Market went up came back
down
hit that level bounced up now people say
Well it traded through so it was
invalidated okay but on this balance
it's actually a three tick sorry a three
point bounce right from what is this
here
63.
this is 63 63 and a quarter bounce it
all the way back up to what is that 66
and a quarter definitely 66 about a
three point move
this one right it came back right in the
next bar tested it and then sold off
here we got another buying and balance
stack buying a balance Market went up
it's holding staying above that level
comes back into that level
right now this one is
a stack bind and balance that's five
levels deep came back in by one two
three levels here
then it ripped to the upside you got
another stack behind a balance here
all right we're trading well above it
here here stacks on a balance came back
into it and came off a little bit
um this binding balance obviously still
holding it's another stack buying a
balance got within one tick of it we're
still holding above it so you know being
able to have these lines drawn on your
chart
just gives you a visual representation
of one you know where there could be
potentially some support or resistance
in the market based off of the
aggressive trading that's taking place
and two if we don't come back into it
you know within a certain time period
then we know that hey you know what
possibly you know we could be looking at
a trending market right because you know
markets have rotations right s PS have
rotations and if it's not sort of
rotating back well then I know that I
had some strong directional trade okay
you know here's another you know this
one came back into it traded through it
went back up got another stack buying a
balance here again traded back into it
now
one thing that you know in my opinion is
is important about order flow is you
know you ideally you want to take
advantage of it especially if it's a
stack
imbalance stacked buying imbalance or
stack selling a balance because you know
that there's
um
strong aggressive trading going on right
now immediately and if you're looking at
you know a five minute chart or even a
15-minute chart on order flow there are
certain things you can look for
on longer term charts but something like
a stacked imbalance I think is best
utilized
as soon as it happens again you know if
it if it happens
on a five minute chart that's all well
and good but you know for example like
this is nine o'clock here to 905 here
and you're gonna have the Stacked in
balance and it's going to show on a five
minute chart because obviously we never
came back into it but
in my opinion you know the sooner you
can take advantage of this stacked
imbalance the better
right it's going to give you in my
opinion a better entry rather than
waiting you know full five minutes for
the market to close because you know
again when you're trading you know
sometimes you get these candles you know
and it starts out as a green candle
and you get all excited and you jump in
but then the candle turns red you know I
always prefer to wait for the candle to
close to give me that confirmation yeah
hey you know what this is a red candle
or yeah that's a green candle
um when trading order flow now if you go
to a 30 second chart I think I got a 30
second chart over here
um you know and people are going to say
well a 30 second chart that that's too
fast I can't trade that
um well you know people that trade
things like book map or even a dome you
know they're trading by the second
honestly
um so you know again it's up to you I'm
not advocating that you have to use a 30
second chart but if you're using a 30
second chart right you're gonna see
things that
a little bit different so you can see
like this is this is that bar with the
stack selling a balance right there let
me just
um go back here right it came back
on the one minute chart it looked like
you know in the next minute it came in
there and tested it and then sold off
but on the 30 second chart right we
actually sold off came back late
in this in the next bar
and came in and tested that zone whereas
you know on the 30 second chart
it came in sold off sold off came back
up and then tested it so you have the
Zone actually being drawn out here
whereas on the one minute chart it's not
being drawn out so
again you know if you're trading stacked
imbalances you might want to use a
quicker chart rather than a slower chart
you know slower meaning you know a five
minute chart
but again I think a one-man chart is
fine
um
for most Traders right again you know
sometimes you know there's there's
um
you know people get excited you know
they see the market moving quickly you
don't want to be on a chart that's going
to get you too excited and into the
markets but
um you know where you're over trading
that's a big problem for Traders but
um yeah I mean a one minute chart is
fine a 30 second chart is fine as well
you could get that grant that you know a
better comprehension of what's happening
in the market on a shorter time frame
but again it's a different style of
trading right I'm not saying off your
five minute Trader and you're successful
at it stick with it stay with what works
for you but I'm just trying to give you
sort of my insights into the market so
anyway guys I'm gonna end it there
um you know stacked imbalances is
something that
um you know is Market generated based
off of the the trading you know it's not
based off of some fancy uh mathematical
equation or anything like that other
than
um
the difference in the two-way auction
right based off of the volume okay
you're looking at a certain percentage
that's about as far as the math goes on
a stacked imbalance right and there's
two parts one you got to have an
imbalance and two it has to be neatly
stacked on top of each other so anyway
guys have a great rest of your day and
I'll catch you guys on the next video
bye-bye